Paul's with us in Sacramento California
hey Paul welcome to the show
well hello babe good to talk to you good
to talk to you sir
so um what is your net worth sir we are
at 1.3 million 1.3 million and what is
your age 52 52 just like the last guy
okay cool
and what's your 1.3 million invested in
the lion's share is in a globally
diversified portfolio the 401 K for my
wife's 403 B and then we've got about
375 equity in our house
okay so retirement in mutual funds it
sounds like am I wrong yes yes okay is
the most of it and then you've got plus
300 K or plus or minus in the house okay
yep okay house I want to write this down
so I don't forget it all right and your
average income through your working life
it's there's been a lot of peaks and
valleys we started at about 50 when we
came to the states in 1992 and we're now
at about 175 so the average is just
below 100 okay so hundred but now at one
sudden if I came to the states where you
from originally the Canadian Prairies
came for grad school in the early 90s
okay cool how much of this one point
three million dollars did you inherit
50k 50k how long ago
that's probably eight years okay so that
did not cause this mathematically then
no what's your career field been through
your you're working I have been in media
and public policy and my wife is now in
Healthcare Informatics okay all right
and what's your degree in I've got three
just like rich before me our public
policy communications okay and your your
GPA you are probably the first person to
ask me that since I graduated 3.8 3.9
okay all right I don't remember mine I
had to go look it up out of three two so
yeah I just it's always make people
think that sometimes the people that are
rich are all geniuses or something and
truthfully the average is a little over
three three and a half right in there
I mean there's very few one-point-six is
in there but there's not a lot of 4.2 z
there so very interesting so what part
did Det used
what part of did you use debt to cause
you to build wealth none of it actually
worked the other way we we didn't get
house fever back in the early 90s but we
did get home improvement fever and it
took a couple of years for us to shake
her head straight on that but it didn't
it didn't help with wealth it it was a
hindrance for the years that we played
around with so the theory of good debt
was a bunch of crap okay so what part
does giving plus giving played in your
financial plan as you become wealthy
well both our folks were big about it
giving at least 10% and we've tried to
stay to that number in the early years
it was a little bit tough and as margin
has increased we've been able to do more
and more and supporting the local church
supporting causes and institutions that
we believe in and also just being able
to help people when we see me you know
what's the most expensive pair of jeans
you or your wife ever bought 30 bucks
and usually less with a coupon at Costco
how many new cars did you buy before you
had a million dollar net worth we bought
two and we're driving them both 20 and
12 years later respectively okay very
cool so what advice have you got for the
25 year old version of you and your wife
they're listening right now keep it
simple
stay away from the fancy stay away from
the scheme's live below your means you
know if you save 10% and you give 10%
you can still live on 80% and with a
little bit of hard work and
determination and lots of communication
you can make this work very cool
well I'm harder to talk to you Paul
you're a great American Hero starting
from nothing became a millionaire there
it is again they're all over the place
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show I want to
write a song I want to own my own
business I want to make more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year to wish